anthony let's see
who brings a little bit of the
entertainment value aside because you've
got to be creative nowadays right you
just can't come out and have a hard time
don't see so many who's just calling out
here you got to tell a story yeah it
pops out on the floor
that's what i'm talking about bring dad
out get him out of retirement bring him
out earlier
[Applause]
hey
okay what's going
[Music]
don't stop watching what you should do
he said go over
to that corner and let me push him off
really quick all right and grab the
basketball that would be more like it
for greg hey listen when you're from new
york city
oh you're gone now you guys all right
hey i don't know what you talking about
but he don't have no scuffs on his terms
either no
you know what that's like that's like a
mclaren
when you got to play tim's back in new
york all right like that's what he saw
so well we know he probably can dunk the
basketball right here
but is there going to be someone in the
regular i think he's going to jump over
that means something if you're talking
take
what does that translate to with tim's
on brand new out of the box
you get about that's another x
oh
[Applause]
dead is he ready
my money my man's dunking in temps
we haven't seen him
this is a new york city thing that
you all are excited about excited hey yo
all you need is a gold chain and a
they should know this better this is
father-son they should they should have
this choreographer look come on kenny
greg is on that long up until
his shoulders talking right now
yeah
call anthony and he's talking to the
judges right now he definitely got us
anticipating what he's about to do no
doubt well he better make the first one
yes indeed come on come on come on boy
get up get up get up
[Applause]
okay gives you a little hint yeah gives
you a little head yeah that was a fake
out he did that on purchase he didn't
even try to dump that that was a fake
guy
it may end up being a grab and a
one-hand dunk i bet that
i think he's going to take his sims off
put his regular shoes on and we're good
you're good we got an explanation no tip
you're good
well we'll be here tomorrow for the
all-star game trying to do this done
let's go let's go
giannis has his phone out over there
doesn't oh as an official attempt
all right let's go let's go he loses
he's losing him he's losing him right
now but it sneaks back over he losing
him
yeah go put your sneaks back on he
losing him he got to get him right now
he's dunked in tim's before
it was the angle yeah that wasn't bad
that wasn't that it wasn't bad that's
like a eight
it's an eight to warm
he's got the crowd on his side he did it
the second time he would have had
everybody
but he got half of us we still never
seen that before though no i like it no
i've seen it before in the parking lot
in the park dudes
like this
[Laughter]
here again in cleveland all right
i would have been more impressed if he
would
just know that first you know he showed
us the migos was like what is that and
fat joe was like that's hot
depending where you ride
where
dominique wilkins isaiah thomas dr j
clyde the glide and david robinson
and this one goes for 40.
so it's all eights how's that eight you
want to start out with eight you don't
want to bring everything out that's
solid solid
yeah i don't know okay i feel like
he's playing catch-up now though
yo
what are y'all where y'all didn't win
tim's in chicago what y'all want
whatever we can get our hands on
come on hand me down